[Music]
imposing stone sentinels stangard on
Rapanui a volcanic island that anchors
the western point of the Polynesian
triangle in the South Pacific you might
know it as Easter Island
[Music]
about 42% of the island is Bravo Nui
National Park a world heritage property
established in 1995 to preserve the
natural and cultural wonders of this
Chilean territory this Polynesian
outposts blossomed in isolation
developing a distinct architectural and
artistic culture moai the enormous heads
that dot the landscape are the lasting
legacy of this ancient society the
effort to construct these monuments and
move them around the island must have
been considerable but no one knows
exactly why the Rapa Nui people
undertook such a task the hundreds of
moai standing on Easter Island today
were restored by historians
anthropologists and archeologists in the
20th century to get the best view of the
moai Trek Toronto Buraku where the
volcanic rock used in their construction
was quarried of the 887 remaining
statues on the island roughly 400 are
strewn in and around the volcanic fader
while most people visit Rapa Nui to
explore its cultural history the island
is also home to some excellent diving
surfing and enticing beaches
it's miraculous that Polynesian people's
ever reached Rapa Nui in the first place
getting there today is much easier but
the island is still very far afield long
flights service Rapa Nui from Chile and
Tahiti
[Music]